hey everybody welcome to the show my
guest today
is radhanath swami he is a teacher
he's an author an activist this guy
is a monk he's an ascetic a renuncian a
proper
sadhu he's also one of the world's most
prominent exponents of
bhakti yoga he's in the house here today
to
share his devotional wisdom we talk
about
what it means to live a spiritual life
the importance of
seva or service the importance of a
spiritual practice
we talk about his community work in
ecological conservation
the inherent power of love to heal what
ails us and
many other topics if you enjoy this
channel it would mean a lot if you could
please
click that subscribe button and hit that
notification bell so
you can be properly alerted when every
new video publishes thank you very much
for that and with that
please enjoy my conversation with the
singular
rajna swamy
swami thank you so much for joining me
today
it's a delight to be in your virtual
presence my only misgiving is that we
couldn't do this in person i hope that
at some point
we get to cross paths in the physical
plane
but for now we are relegated to zoom and
i just
appreciate you taking the time to talk
to me today
rich i'm so honored so grateful and so
very happy to be with you today
i can feel your presence already there's
so many uh
so many things i want to talk to you
about to explore with you
but i think i'd like to begin this by
spending a little bit of time talking
about
our present moment we just feel
so divided currently everybody seems to
be
siloed in their respective information
cells
emotions are running very hot people are
spending a lot of time
defending their respective positions
signaling their membership in good
standing
to their respective tribes and i'm
seeing this
breakdown in our ability to
effectively communicate to listen to one
another to understand
each other and all of this of course is
being heightened by
the many crises that we're currently
facing both
existential as well as practical from
the pandemic
to global warming right now greenland is
melting california is on fire
we're seeing hurricanes on the horizon
and of course
amplified by our inflamed political
landscape and all of this is leaving me
fearing for
our sanity and the stability of our
future
i see anxiety getting ratcheted up and
i'm just
interested in hearing your sense of our
our current moment
and perhaps how we can find our way
to some place of of healing as a nation
as a global community to
unite around our many shared values uh
you know how do we raise our collective
consciousness and
restore some semblance of of cultural
cohesion so that we can write this
beautiful
mothership earth that we call home
that's a big one
[Laughter]
it's really a big one i'm looking to you
for the answers
but really in whatever situation
the world may be in because it's always
changing
you know this is the most important
question
when things are in a very
prosperous pleasant state
we know that that's going to change and
when things are in a very critical
um painful state we know that's going to
change
too so it's really important
that we we find
the foundation within ourselves and
among
ourselves that really is meaningful and
purposeful in life
you know pain is pain is so inevitable
as death is inevitable in this world
but there's something beautiful in life
there's something beautiful in creation
there's something beautiful in our
in our own self that's always there
and it's always waiting for us and
um we can do the greatest good for the
world when we're connected to
that and we help we help one another to
connect to that
so what is the process of
creating that connection you know at
times
at times like this
sometimes we we take for granted
the light of life
until we're surrounded by darkness
then we really look for the light and
and
and we really appreciate that the light
is there and these particular times
throughout history many of the greatest
accomplishments in art and science
and in in in religion spirituality
in architecture you know have happened
at times
of great challenge you know
oftentimes challenging situations
brings the best out in people or could
also bring the worst out in people
and that's just a choice that each and
every one of us
could make
in the alcoholics anonymous organization
which i've been invited to speak to on
several occasions
you know there's there's a unity a
beautiful unity among the people
on the basis of the crisis
that they have been through and to a
certain extent that they're going
through
um because they they understand
that like-mindedness is so important
in this world you know despite people's
differences in background and despite
people's differences of ideologies
there's something urgent that we
have in common that we could really
focus on
and um you know as you said so nicely
rich
you know the environment and
and this pandemic and the political
landscape there's so much
so much to be concerned with um
we we need to find like-minded
people um we need to find unity
in diversity where we could actually
nourish and inspire one another because
you know unity has the greatest strength
and that unity becomes stronger and
stronger
when each individual um
helps others to cultivate their own
individual strength
and purpose and and that's where that's
where a spiritual practice
is is really important where we actually
go to that power to that grace
to that goodness that's inherent within
our own hearts within our own souls and
tap
into that and be an instrument of of
god's love of spiritual love
and and share that with one another and
it's beyond a sectarian idea
it's beyond a nationalistic idea it's
beyond a
racial idea it's beyond you know where
every living being is
sacred the whole creation
is inherently sacred but we can't really
appreciate that
unless until we understand that i am
sacred the living force within me is
sacred i don't have to compare myself to
anyone or
anything i just have to be the best i
could be
for god and for other people and for
other living beings
and the more we share this and the more
we
we take this serious to practice it the
more
individually and collectively we could
actually
do something really wonderful in this
world and there can be
there could be positive transformations
of
light and we have to be we have to be
searching for that light
and we have to be moving toward that
light together
i appreciate the optimism and the
enthusiasm
for a brighter future and i love what
you had to say about
how things like compassion forgiveness
begin with the self like we can't exude
that compassion or that forgiveness for
others until we extend it to
our own beings it's very difficult for a
lot of people i've had my own
journey with that and in
alcoholics anonymous which i also love
that you referenced that i've been a
member of that community for
23 years at this point they say
you can't transmit something you haven't
got you can't be compassionate to others
unless you are inherently compassionate
and that compassion
begins with self-compassion and
what's beautiful about that community is
exactly what you said
that it is not about politics or
religious proclivity it's about
sharing a common experience for the
betterment of all
it's about looking past our differences
and identifying
the similarities they say to people when
they come in
don't look for the differences try to
identify with what you relate to
try to find your own story in the
collective stories of the people that
are sharing
and i try to take that sensibility
into the world because it is so precious
and beautiful
and to see so many lives healed and
lives transformed as a result of this
collective
experience is not only a successful
experiment in that subculture but is a
beautiful template that i think is
applicable to all
i would only like to see it more broadly
embraced and explored in
society at large thank you so very much
it's so true what you say
there there was a great saint in india
who wrote something that really had a
deep impact in my heart
that i refer to when there's times of
challenge
he said where there's the greatest
need there's the greatest opportunity
to serve and
compassion really is the foremost of all
human virtues
and it's the deepest most inherent
nature that's within everyone
where there's love it's expressed as
compassion and where there's great need
there's great necessity and
and in in you referred to also the
alcoholics anonymous people come
together because
there's a need people need to hold on to
each other's support
you know right now in california there's
there's these
fires and it really breaks my heart
especially
it it's such a blessing to the world
the redwood forests where these trees
that have been
standing and growing for
thousands of years um
and there's an underground secret in the
redwood forest that i learned from a
park ranger when i was there once
that despite all the storms
and the fires and all things that have
happened
over these centuries how do the trees
keep growing
especially on loose soil and
hilly regions because the roots of the
trees their nature is to reach out
underground to find the roots of other
trees
and when they touch each other they
embrace
they wrap around each other and in this
way all the
trees of the whole forest are directly
or
indirectly supporting each other by
embracing one another's roots
coiling coiling around each other the
giant
ancient trees have the little tiny
trees that are just growing their roots
are wrapped around and they're all
supporting each other
and it's true unity is strength
um you know the whole concept of of
of america is the united states of
america
and and there's the united kingdom
you know there's union is such an
important
principle and the basic
um ideal of that union
is that all people are created
equal all living beings are children of
god
how we actually find love within our own
self
is how we will respect and
honor and
be compassionate to to all living beings
because
life is sacred and
at times like this we really
need to understand this is a wake up
call to wake up to the sacredness of
life and and and put aside
our egoistic and selfish ambitions
because
there's a higher principle there's a
more important principle
it's beautifully put um i love the
analogy
of the root system and how the
collective
um thrives only in embracing that
interdependence
and when i think of the the the united
states
of america i can't help but think of the
countervailing force
which is rugged individualism this idea
that
that responsibility for your success or
your failure or how you make your way
into the world rests solely upon one's
shoulders
and this kind of hoisting up
of the individual and the responsibility
of that person to do it themselves to
make their own way to be a self-made man
is at odds with that fundamental core
idea of the united states of america and
the inherent
truth and need that we only thrive
through our communion with others and
our interdependence with the greater
whole
and reconciling those i think is a is a
battle that we're seeing being waged
culturally right now
and i guess i would say that that i wish
i shared your
optimism and your enthusiasm for us
seeing our way through this
successfully and of course you're a
little bit older than me your life
experience is informed by
perhaps the most similar phase in the
history of our country
you know weathering through the 60s the
late 60s the civil rights era
and all the kind of beautiful chaos that
ensued there the trauma and also the
progress that was a result of that
and i'm wondering if you see what's
happening now
as something similar or distinct from
what you witnessed throughout that
period
the 60s were a very turbulent time
you know there was a large
segment of the younger generation
revolted against
the older generation the government the
politics
you know the war in vietnam was
something very real
if you were 18 years old and you didn't
have some
a lot of wealth for a deferment then
you either had to kill people that you
saw no reason to harm
or you go to jail
you know you were you were actually put
in that situation
you know it was a war that many people
did not believe
we should be there and um it turned out
correct also and the civil rights
movement
you know there was so many atrocities
that have always been against the
african-american community in
in america it's just so heartbreaking
um but we see that you know
through the the the dark eras
and through the through the conflicts
and the challenges
many great things have come from that
um many transformations within people's
hearts and many transformations within
the society
so i firmly believe
and and history um i believe echoes this
idea that as long as there are
individual people
who are connecting with other
like-minded individual people
who are really looking for the light and
who are really connecting to the light
within themselves
and valuing the principle of love and
compassion and humility
then wonderful things will happen within
this world
well i feel nourished by that statement
thank you for that why don't we take it
back
i i want to explore your personal
journey
now that we're speaking about the 60s
and the civil rights movement
you grew up in chicago middle class
family outside of the city right your
dad was a
uh he owned an auto body shop if i if
memory serves me like you grew up you
were like a
you were an athlete you were a wrestler
you grew up you know very
in a very typical normal somewhat
suburban
middle america household correct
something like that
some version of that
you encapsulated very very well
um yes when i was young my
my parents were struggling middle middle
class
you know they were they were really
struggling you know they came out of the
depression
and and they were really trying
to to do the best for the family
at the same time this the scenario that
we have already discussed
you know civil rights vietnam war
counter culture they they were unfolding
as i was growing up
um i was born in 1950 and i just
could not be content just winning some
athletic medals or being
cool and having inner nice things
unless i could be a change um
so where do you think that that
sensibility emanated from i know
you showed uh you know indications of
this as a young as a very young child
like not wanting to sit at the table
wanting to sit it on the floor for
dinner and
eschewing meat and dairy and and and
sort of demonstrating
these sodastic impulses
as a very young person which is unusual
right like so where do you think all of
that was coming from
is this a you know past life made
manifest or how do you think about that
um
past life made manifest
um transformation through experiences in
this
life and ultimately i believe god's
grace
you know he's all all these things come
into play
we may or may not be able to
specifically understand the reasons
but we can understand the effects
that are happening and and there are so
many little things
that that happen a person's life that
gradually
create a perception
um i'll i'll say one thing
that when i was young my father went
through bankruptcy
so when i got a little older
maybe 14 15 years old i always had jobs
after school
and on weekends just
so i wouldn't be a burden and my first
job was in a place where
it was mainly african-americans who were
there
it was at a car wash and they were
coming from the south side of chicago
and they were my parents age and they
became my
dear friends and i i just loved
them i loved their music i loved
the spirit that they had so
deeply and i
saw how you know in those days in the
early 60s they really
hardly had a chance they were most of
them were alcoholics they were in
poverty
they were discriminated against they
were treated unfairly
and this
so much disturbed me
it so much disturbed me i was
i felt that you know we were one
in our love for each other and how could
i be happy if my brothers are being
treated like this
um and
of course you know my
i'm my family is from jewish
ancestry you know from eastern europe
and so many of the people from my family
who were killed in the holocaust
uncles and aunts and cousins and like
that
so you know there's this
dark side of humanity
that needs to be changed
there's the saying if you're not part of
the solution you are part of the problem
and i really wanted to be a part of the
solution and i heard gandhi's statement
that be the change you want to be in
this world
so i became a social activist
but then i came to an understanding that
the greatest social activists
that i admired were people who had a
deep
spiritual connection
a connection to god's love which
actually gave them
strength against all challenge
and unless we change ourselves
you know how much can we really change
the world
so little by little i went on a
spiritual quest
to find myself and
that became the very predominant
goal of my life is to is to have a
spiritual
connection yeah and in my own life i
traveled across the world looking for
that spiritual connection
but what i ultimately discovered is it's
right within our heart
right within our own home wherever we
are if we can't find it there we really
can't find it anywhere but i
i had to go through this great journey
to come to that discovery
well there's a beautiful nobility and uh
you know uh uh a large
um maturity to develop that kind of
awareness as such a young person
to understand like i am here to be an
agent of positive change and to
shoulder that mantle and to try to
figure that out
in your case you go on this walkabout
you describe it in your books and in
your many talks
and when i read this i can't help but
think about
some of the other great spiritual
seekers over the
ages from paramahansa yogananda
to you know sid you i think of
siddhartha and i think of
ramadas and all these people that have
had similar versions of your experience
and i compare that to my mindset at
16 17 18 and it's in such
stark contrast that expanded awareness
that
devotional commitment and that sense
that there is something more
beyond you know the athletic medals or
trying to be
popular in the hallways of your high
school that
is unique and so i'm still trying to get
at
like that sensibility i understand you
had these experiences as a young person
but
there were a lot of people that had
experiences like that they may carry
that trauma or
that may inform their life in a certain
regard but
to shed the shackles of
western society completely and to give
yourself over
in this ascetic way to go on this
walkabout you know basically penniless
relying on the kindness of strangers and
all the adventures that ensue
is you know is is is such a
beautiful way of trying to um
develop the awareness that you carry
today i'm not so sure
that it would have happened had you not
experienced the world in that
manner we all have our calling
and it's not really so important what
age we have that calling
but when that calling for goodness when
that calling for truth when that calling
for light when that
calling to be the change that you want
to see in the world
and i i deeply believe it's it's god's
calling
coming from within us which could echo
from
around us through other voices too but
ultimately it's a calling from within
we all have our ways of responding to
that calling to
but in my life you know this is how i
responded to that calling
yeah i suppose in order to heed whatever
calling
is happening you have to be present and
aware enough
to notice it's arising
and and sometimes situations in the
world
that are startling that are worrisome
even sometimes situations that appear
hopeless
um they
alert us to responding to that calling
so you find yourself in london you're
trekking about europe
you're in athens you're sitting on the
banks of the thames in london at night
soaking in the moon watching the river
flow
at some point you have this undeniable
urge or calling to go to india so walk
me through
that experience well you know
coming from northern illinois
um
i went to europe with two of my friends
we were supposed to be there for just
two months and then come back
for um going back to college
i went to one semester of a college
and that was the plan that was our plan
um but we got re we got robbed the first
day we were in europe
and we had no money and one of my
friends
went back to america that same day and
the and the other
you know we made the scene in various
places
and we were very popular and
in in many ways
we saw there was the world was opening
up to us like anything even though we
really didn't have a home or money or
anything just because
you know the interactions with such
beautiful people and such opportunities
um but this calling
this little whisper to find
a spiritual connection was always there
in my heart and it was getting louder
and louder and louder
and that's really what started
me on this quest um i was
spending a lot of time on riverbanks and
in forests
and i was meditating and reading various
spiritual literatures from various
religions i was going to synagogues i
was going to churches i was going to
cathedrals
i lived in catholic monasteries i was
studying i was searching
i was going to museums to study art to
find
spiritual clues and eventually i was
living in a
cave on the isle of crete which is part
of greece
and i was just praying to god for
direction
it was there that i had this
voice within my heart that said go to
india
and i had never met an indian person in
my life i've
never ate a chili pepper in my life i
had no map
i had no money for a map but i just left
my friend
the next day and started hitchhiking
to india
i just believed if i just go in the
eastern direction eventually
you're gonna get there occasion
eventually right you travel through
afghanistan you're immersed in extreme
poverty in that situation you're in
pakistan you have this
extraordinary story about getting caught
up at the border between
pakistan and india can you tell that
story
well i hitchhiked through turkey
and then iran and then
through afghanistan and pakistan
um the whole trip took
over four months now i get on an
airplane and i
from london and i do it in nine hours
the same amount of distance but it's not
as
educational but it's much safer for sure
when i finally when i was in the
european countries i was studying
christianity and judaism when i was in
the middle east i was studying islam
from some islamic scholars and very holy
people actually
and when i finally
came to the border of india
india and pakistan you know have been in
conflict politically for
you know since the partition
and there's a no man's land between the
two countries and
when i left the border of pakistan i had
to walk
a couple hours through this no man's
land
to get to india and at that time
the border post was in a forest near the
city of farospor
in punjab and when i arrived
they asked how much money i had
as far as i remember i had 26 cents
in about four different currencies
and the immigration agent was very very
angry
she said that we have enough beggars in
india we don't want another one
go back to where you came from
and i pleaded with her
that i just hitchhiked from london
and i got so many diseases that almost
killed me and people tried to kill me
and so many
difficulties i had to get here because i
want
to learn from your people please give me
a chance
and um she wouldn't do it
so for hours and hours and hours i was
just sitting under a tree and kept
coming back and
asking and getting rejected
but the problem was i couldn't go back
to pakistan either because i only had
a one-time visa so i was in this no
man's land and there were no cell phones
in 19
this was 1970. and there was
no phone booths there was nova i was
just there
um and finally just around the sunset
time
the guards changed and one man from the
sikh
community who was a soldier took
took the post and after the other
immigration drove
off in a jeep i went to him
and this man said to me
that i have been ordered by my
commanding officer
to reject you unless you show me at
least two hundred dollars
um at that point
i cried and i really cried because
you know i was 19 years old and i
it was hopeless and i begged
i said i've i've given up everything of
my life
to learn from your country and to learn
for your people
please just give me a chance
and i promise you that someday i'll do
something good for the people of india
and being an immigration agent he
looked into my eyes with such a
interrogating glance he was just looking
into my
mind and into my heart for about a
minute he just stared at me
and then he spoke he said
sometimes a man must follow his heart
and even though i have been ordered to
reject you
i am going to give you the chance that
you're crying for
and then he stamped my passport and said
welcome to india
i love that that's beautiful i feel like
you need to reunite with him
i would like to see you visit him again
and recount that story to him i wish we
could
yeah but that was
this year marks
50 years since that event happened
and so what was it about this experience
in in
india that was so compelling and
transformative for you
well i was i went to the himalayas
and i was studying from
from yogi's some of them were living in
the forests and mountains and in caves
and i was going to different ashrams of
different
saints or gurus some of them were very
famous
some of them were unknown to the world
i was studying burmese buddhism
and zen buddhism and tibetan buddhism
and i was i was
i met people who were from the baha'i
faith i was really
trying to understand and of course
within the hindu faith there's so many
different branches
of ways of approaching the one supreme
being
so i was just like a little sponge that
was
absorbing and absorbing and absorbing
and learning
and many situations
were such blessings to my heart
some of them were very disappointing and
some of them were
enthralling and and so full of
joy and gratitude um
but they all kind of were
were bringing me forward in my in my
search and and rich i ended up like this
i know look at you who would have known
right
was part of this this quest an effort
or an attempt to to reconcile
uh the hypocrisy of many of the
religious traditions that you'd grown up
around like this idea that
that there is a um there's something
unhealthy about the institutionalization
of many of these ideas and face but
beneath all of that
there must be some kernel of shared
insight and wisdom
and the quest is about getting to
the truth of that is that a fair
assessment
thank you so much for asking that
question
um it's a wonderful assessment
and i'll i'll just echo what you have
already so
brilliantly spoken you know from my own
experience
both as a child
as i was growing up and as i was
traveling on my
quest i saw
so much sectarian
ideas i saw
how religion could create
or let us say could nourish so much
arrogance that i am better than you
and we are better than them
and that arrogance
lee can lead to prejudice
to judging people on the basis
of our own ego and even to hatred
bigotry and violence
in the name of god how could there be
hatred
in the name of a loving god
so i came to a crossroads
where either i had to completely reject
religion
as many very thoughtful people that i
was reading about
and meeting personally they were
rejecting god and religion
because of all the things i just
said so i either have to reject religion
as being something very dangerous or
very superstitious
or there must be something very
beautiful something very
wonderful that's at the heart of all
great religions
and somehow in my life i believed
that that beautiful essence was there at
the heart of all true spiritual paths
and i wanted to find it and as i was
searching
i found that that when people have
the insecurities where they need
to feel above others
they take religion
as as a justification sometimes even as
a weapon
to just for that purpose
but actually the whole purpose of
religion is
to become completely humble and
free of ego it's supposed to free us of
our ego it's not supposed to nourish and
build our ego
but that's based on free will
like anything we could use science for
destructive purposes or we could use
science
for very beneficial purposes we can use
education academia to help people or we
can use it to exploit people
we can use strength to
to uplift people or to push people down
everything in this world you know we
have
a knife is it good or bad in the hands
of a thief it kills someone and the same
knife in the hands of a surgeon
cures someone saves a person's life
so religion is like that too if we're
really looking for the true
purpose of religion what the what the
actual saints
taught us what's at the heart of the
scriptures
then we find that
it's to humble ourself before god's love
and to be an instrument of that love
and to see every living being
as god's children and when i read the
bhagavad-gita
a particular verse i remember
when i read it i thought this is it
because in the bible it has said the
first and great commandment is not to be
this religion or that religion it's to
love god with all your heart mind and
soul
and to love your neighbor as yourself
and actually everyone's our neighbor
not only all humanity but all living
beings are our neighbors
if we love god we will naturally love
our neighbor as ourself
if we know ourself and
that was a very important principle and
then i read in the bhagavad-gita
and i'm gonna i'm gonna recite the
sanskrit first
okay
true knowledge true wisdom
true enlightenment
is to see every living being
with equal vision
to see that the living force
wherever there's life is a part of god
is sacred it's divine and when we
understand that divinity within ourself
we actually can recognize it within
others
and then it's not just about tolerating
one another
and tolerating our differences it's
actually
appreciating the unity within the
diversity of this world
and the more i i went into the religion
of bhakti
or devotion to krishna that i follow
the more i went deep into that the more
i really loved
and appreciated all other aspects of
religion and spirituality because
it it was
i was looking for the essence
and you found that in bhakti yoga i mean
you you know over the course of your
your travels and you're you're seeking
and you're searching you've
sat at the feet of many a master from
krishnamurti and all kinds of people
but there was something specific about
prabhabot that spoke to you
um that didn't immediately compel you to
you know relinquish everything and
follow him
you know it seems like you crossed paths
with him many a time before
you fully embraced that this would be
you know somebody to follow and that
this methodology this
this approach to spirituality this you
know guidebook for living
would become a guiding force in in your
life but
what was it about or is it about
prabhubat's message and specifically
bhakti yoga that distinguished it from
many of these other
you know sort of spiritual strains and
the various you know
paths you could have explored with
hinduism
and you know many other strains of
religion
from christianity to judaism
for me rich
bhakti yoga puts its greatest
emphasis both in the goal and in the
practice
in cultivating love love for god
and compassion for all beings
there's a beautiful statement para du ka
duki
that one who's really enlightened in any
religion
is one who
feels the sufferings of others
and who feels the joys of others
one who rejoices in the happiness of
others and one who suffers in the
suffers of suffering another
but when we suffer for the sufferings of
other on the basis of compassion
that actually creates
an inner ecstasy because
it connects us to our own natural love
and bhakti is that path
which is very much focused on awakening
ecstatic love and to
and whatever our words whatever our
actions were
whatever our thoughts were really trying
to harmonize
that in a spirit of compassion to others
and i found that in that sense
humility doesn't make one fearful
it actually makes ones very courageous
but not in a egoistic selfish way we
understand there's a higher power that's
with us and that higher power is meant
to heal us and to help
us to heal others and in bhakti yoga
the idea of the supreme truth
is very personal you know there's an
all-pervading
absolute uh omniscient omnipresent
existence of the one supreme
but the the scriptures of india teach
simultaneous to that the impersonal
all-pervading truth
or light there's also this
the supreme all beautiful all-loving
person of the supreme
and that idea
that realization and meeting people who
were connected with that
um it just attracted my heart so
deeply and when i when i met provopod i
met him several times
and it was in brindaban where i was
living
a place where there's over 5000 temples
of krishna
some of them are thousands of years old
when i was living there on the bank of a
river the yamuna
i happened to meet pro but he came there
for a few days
and i had already accepted the path of
bhakti just by
my own experiences and my own
studies that this is what i wanted to
follow
but i didn't know who my teacher would
be and i remember i was sitting in a
room
with srila prabhupada and and there were
i heard his talks i heard about him
and it very much opened my heart
and one thing that really had a special
effect on me
is there was just a few people in the
room one day
and one was a i think a journalist
and he asked are you the guru for the
whole world
and by this time srila prabhupad
had thousands of disciples and he had
temples all over the world
and i was wondering how is he going to
answer this
and sheila probably was sitting on the
floor as we all were
and when he asked that when he was asked
that question he looked down
and i saw such a sense
of humility in his eyes
and then he looked up and he said
no i'm just the servant
of everyone that's all
and i was thinking
of all the people i met you know people
who could perform miracles i saw so many
of these supernatural
powers and people who had so much
knowledge and so much
you know powers of so many ways
i felt this is what i want
that expression of genuine humility
spoke to you
i that type of
love where you're so humbled by by
your love for god you just want to serve
everyone and
you could do that as a business person
and you could do that
as a politician and you could do that as
a
teacher and you you could do that as a
technology
or a scientist with and and and
when you have
the ambition of compassion
in the forefront of your heart to please
god then you're more motivated
than greed sometimes people think
without greed what will be our
motivation
but it's only due to an absence of love
and compassion that that
greed comes into our life when we
actually have that
we're even more motivated a mother's
love for her child she'll do
anything and everything she'll stay up
night after
night to help her child because there's
love
and you know the greatest the greatest
people who have
changed the world have worked tirelessly
and risked
everything on the basis of compassion
and love and
and it's it's that principle that
attracted me to pearl part and attracted
me to this path
well you certainly exude it and in your
recounting
i'm thinking of this distinction between
my inclination to intellectualize it
like i understand that that makes sense
i get it versus the embodiment
of it and the practice of it and the
exuding of it
in all of your interactions and in how
you
you know sort of walk through the world
and encounter people
and nature those are two different
things and i think in our western mind
we want to we we're we're prone we're
kind of driven
to live in our heads and to
intellectualize these things
and that is very different from the
experience of
living and breathing it well philosophy
intellectualization is something that
has such great value
if we have the capacity for that but if
we don't
we could still achieve the same thing
but when the heart and the head are
harmonized
then um
we could really move in in a beautiful
direction in our life
i prabhupad once said
that philosophy without spirituality
is just mental speculation
and spirituality without philosophy
can degrade to sentimentalism
or superstition or even fanaticism
so the the harmonizing of philosophy
and spirituality and when i say
spirituality that means
you know having a practice in which
we're really striving to live with
character
yeah i believe that we're all here to
walk that path in our own respective
and unique ways to become more fully
actualized
and integrated that connection between
the head and the hearts and in my own
personal experience
pain has been my lever in order to help
me
wake up and and start to grapple with
many of these issues
and to come to an awareness and
understanding
that although we instinctively know that
the material world
like consumerist goods power fame none
of these things are going to fill
this hole that we all have that they're
not going to say to us they're not going
to sustain us or
give us that sense of wholeness that
that we yearn for that we seek and yet
like addicts we pursue these things to
the depths of
depravity and insanity until we meet
that
personal pain point and then when we
reach that we think
well if i just get that promotion or if
i can just lease that new car
or i can move out of this neighborhood
and to the other neighborhood
then that hole will be filled then i
will feel fine
so i think it takes quite a bit
to compel the human mind
to broaden itself and entertain the
possibility
because of the strictures of our culture
and how materialistic it is
and the messages that we're being
constantly bombarded by
that that the true path to happiness and
fulfillment
lies beyond all of this and and
and breaking that um
that denial coming into that awareness
is
is a difficult journey for most
so well said it's like if we're on a
ship
on the sea um
it's really important we have a compass
that we're going in the direction of our
desired destination but the compass that
we're sort of given
is do well in school
go to the right college get the right
job
you know work hard and then you can get
the stuff
and then everything is going to be fine
like that's the compass that's the
that's that's how we calibrate our
decision making
and yet we know intellectually
that this is leading us awry and yet
it's so difficult to recalibrate that
compass according to
a spiritual principle well
the the idea of satsang or the company
of enlightened people
is important because then we get
a real life compass
not you know not the wrong compass
we want to actually have a life compass
that actually gives our life
deep profound meaning and purpose
and you know this is what all the
avatars the incarnations of god
and all the saints they're giving us a
compass
and then when we're on the ship
there's so many things it's not that we
just follow the compass
there's so many things we have to do
simultaneously
you know sometimes there's a storm and
we have to make all kinds of adjustments
sometimes it's a nice day and we have to
keep things clean and we have to think
keep things and
there's so much we have to do but at the
same time
we're going in the direction
that we really want to be and in the
same way
like what you're saying we have to pay
the rent and we want
some of us want new cars and some of us
want some popularity and all these
things
of this world they're there we deal with
them
you know we have sometimes we have
parents that don't understand us and
sometimes we have children that don't
understand us
there's so many challenges in life being
spiritual
doesn't mean neglecting those duties
whether they're financial or emotional
or social
it doesn't mean that we
ignore them doesn't mean we reject them
it means we deal with all of them
but with in harmony with the
compass of where our life
really is meant to be
where we want to go as spiritual beings
having a human experience and as much as
as you are a renunciant you too
live in the material world you dress in
a certain way and you carry yourself in
a certain regard
and you spend your time in india and you
do these things but you are still
of the third dimension you still have to
operate
in 2020 right as much as you might want
to opt out of that
of course i'm more immersed in in you
know modern culture
than you are and that brings its own
unique challenges
so the practice then becomes how do we
bring these principles
into our life and infuse our our mindset
and our daily actions
with that energy is it
you know what is the practice for you is
it ahimsa is it seva
is it devotion is it prayer is it
compassion is it love it is all these
things
how do we do that how do we bring more
of that
into our into the daily life experience
of of the average person who is perhaps
listening or watching to this
and being introduced to these ideas for
maybe the first time
in sanskrit there's four words
and i'd like to explain these four
practices
satsang means if we really want that
compass to be going toward a divine
enlightened destination
if we really want to
connect with god's love and be an
instrument of god's love we need that
compass
and that comes by regularly
as much as possible
being with like-minded people
being with enlightened people you know
we have a choice of what we're going to
read
and who we're going to be with and we
need regular
um nourishment to give us
confidence that this is where i want to
go
and the second is sadhana when we really
have a spiritual
purpose in our life
it's not just something sentimental it
has to actually be practice
we have to give some time
of the day to cultivate that
just like somehow or other whatever we
have to do in our life with our families
or our occupation
we find time to eat we find time to
sleep
because without that we become weak so
spiritually in order to have a spiritual
strength in whatever we do
we need to nourish ourselves and that's
sadhana
and in my sadhana we chant god's names
we chant mantras we also pray
and putting some
time aside each day
early morning is a really good time
whatever time
where we're actually focusing on our
spiritual practice
making it a priority
and then when we go out into the world
with the strength and the direction
from the people who inspire us
and our own spiritual practice then we
live with integrity we live with
character
we don't we don't perform our
our worldly activities with excessive
arrogance or selfishness or greed
or envy but rather we actually do it
with
with moral principles
with character and ultimately we're
trying to
harmonize whatever we're doing in a way
that we can best be compassionate to our
family and to the world
and then seva then
whatever we're doing in our life it all
becomes part of how we're serving god
and serving
all of our brothers and sisters of all
species of life within this world
and that's something that's totally
doable and totally
practical for everyone in whatever
situation we may be in
if we just
take it seriously and make it a priority
beautifully put can we spend a couple
minutes talking about the joppa
the mantra and what it is that is so
powerful about the repetition
and the sequencing of these words that
creates that
very particular vibration that i've
sensed and and
experienced that allows me to tap into
something
i don't know what to call it beyond or
more profound than my ego
which i love to cultivate
the word mantra is two sanskrit
syllables
mantra man means the mind
or the heart and thra
means to liberate so mantra means
a sound vibration that liberates the
mind
from suffering and from pain which are
caused by pollution
that the mind is compared to a mirror
and when you look in a mirror you expect
to see yourself
but when the mirror is covered by layers
and layers and
layers of dirt and pollution
and debris after so many years of
neglect then what do we see when we look
in the mirror we just see
that dirt
and what is that dirt it's our
selfish passions it's our arrogance
it's our greed our envy our
anger at people and things that just
don't go the way
i want them to go and so many illusions
of misconceiving who
i am and who and what the world is
so this is the dirt and a mantra
is a sound vibration that actually has
the power to
clean the mirror of the mind and as it's
cleaned
we actually see ourself and who is the
self
that the self is the living
force that's seen through the eyes and
hearing through the ears and tasting
through the tongue
and thinking through the brain that
living
force that animates a body that gives
consciousness and that living force in
sanskrit is this
the atma or the soul
and that soul is never born
and it never dies
that soul is a sacred part
of the supreme soul it's full of light
its inherent nature is
unmotivated unconditional
love that's the nature of the soul
within everyone but due to the various
um coverings over the mirror of the mind
we're not seeing our soul we're not
living accordingly
the mind is supposed to reflect
the nature of this of the person
of the soul um so this mantra
is a cleaning process an awakening
process
as we become cleaned of these
um anarchists or unwanted
characteristics that we're clinging to
our natural innate ananda or happiness
is awakened and when we're happy within
then nothing of this world can make us
really unhappy because
our happiness is beyond all the things
of this world
right and then we simply want to be an
instrument of that happiness
to make others happy vedic literatures
is a beautiful verse
the whole purpose of religion of
spirituality
is let all beings be
happy to be an instrument to give
happiness
to others so that's what this mantra
does
and it's like a frequency
it's a divine spiritual frequency a
mantra is usually composed of names of
god and there are many
names of god in all the various
religious paths
and these mantras or these names of god
when
chanted with the right temperament with
the right purpose
they they actually tune us in
to the divinity that's within us and all
around us
just like a on a television there are so
many
channels and if you press one station
you go to a frequency where you see a
football game in
dallas texas and then you press another
one and you see
the president of the united states
giving a lecture and then you see it
you press another one and you see a soap
opera people are crying and
loved ones are separated and
there's according to the frequency you
get
a completely different experience so
within the world today
there's so many accumulated frequencies
there's the
there's the accumulated frequency of
arrogance and lust and
envy and anger and and prejudice
and and all of these things and
according to
what we do and who we're with we tune
into those frequencies
and they affect us a mantra is the
frequency of love
a frequency of compassion a frequency of
inner happiness and
peace and when we chant sincerely
and and and our lifestyle is not
um contradicting the progress we make
then through joppa or through chanting
god's names
we actually awaken by
tuning into our true
inherent potential hmm
beautifully put the irony
of course is that most people
are are are living their lives you know
subsumed by the maya
right their mirrors are obscured and
polluted
and there is no sense of what it would
be like for that mirror
to be cleaned because the maya is so
all-consuming right the delusion of our
material world
and i reflect back on
my youth and i would see hari krishna
monks
at the airport chanting or in the you
know the parks
and just thinking that's another
version of humanity that i can't connect
with like i don't
not only do i not understand what's
going on with these individuals i was
you know sort of scared of it and
i remember that being a barrier
when i started to open up to different
ideas around spirituality it was a
barrier to me
embracing the practice of joppa like if
i'm gonna chant hari krishna then
suddenly i'm like those guys
in the airport that i thought were so
odd
that i couldn't connect with that i
couldn't relate to
how do you communicate to the average
human being who
who doesn't have experiences with these
things
so that they can they can kind of
overcome whatever barrier they may have
because of the superficiality
of of appearance does that make sense
do you know what i'm getting at
[Laughter]
i was trying to be very politic in how i
described that
it was beautifully stated thank you
it is a reality that our our tendency is
to see things according to our external
perceptions without really understanding
um you know like that beautiful
speech that martin luther king gave in
washington d.c
when will that i have a dream
that people will not see will not judge
a person by the color of their skin but
by the
content of their character
so um you know when i was
living in the west you know i
i had the same experience as far as
strangeness
mm-hmm you know things that are were
just very different and hard to
understand
and look at you now and and when i went
to
india it wasn't really in the context
of the western krishna movement but it
was
i saw and i found and i discovered
within my own life something so
beautiful that was so
deep and inherent within the culture of
india which was so universal at the
heart of all religions really you know
heart of all
humanity and i found that
and then when i
reconnected in brindaban especially a
holy place
with the people from the krishna
movement
the birthplace of krishna yes yes
i understood that you know
in the west it may seem strange
the dress and it may seem strange
the cultural habits but
it's what's at the heart of it and
there's also a lot of people who just
don't represent properly right
you know the real spirit right the
institutionalization
of the teachings that's true with any
path there's those who really represent
the real spirit and those who don't
and that's their you know we all
struggle with that
but when i saw that this is at the heart
of what
is being taught is a culture and a
philosophy
and a lifestyle that's
that's at the very core
of the vedas at the very core of
of india's culture and religion
and at the very core of what i believe
the universe
of of religion itself and
and that's really why i became like this
and there are various you know cultural
traditional ways of expressing it
and um you know i i just find
so much joy and so much enlightenment in
in this way of expressing it but i
understand
that there's so many ways of expressing
it
and in fact i live in india for
for many many decades now and
you know we have you know several
communities
um that i oversee and
there are monks who are like me because
this is really the
the robes and the dress of a monk yeah
but we have tens and thousands of people
who
who have families who are working
we have a hospital with doctors and
nurses and
administrators we have industrialists
there are ceos of international
corporations there's farmers there's
professors at colleges there's
mothers and fathers and um
in the congregation you would only
know that their devotees of krishna
by their character and by
communicating with them in that way but
otherwise they look just like everybody
and they're doing exactly the same
things as everyone as far as you know
occupational life
but the purpose is
to connect with god's love and to be an
instrument
of god's compassion and and that's a
beautiful thing and
my mother and father when they came to
india and they saw people
like them who were so
deeply devoted um
and then they understood
relief that that actually
this is really a beautiful spiritual
path right
and not everybody's going to be a monk
yeah
i watched a a youtube interview with
your dad
uh he was recounting the experience of
what it was like for him when you
left and were in parts unknown and you
know the challenges that that
presented for you know basically in
middle-class family um but
what was undeniable was his love and his
pride for
for what you ultimately became it's it's
it's it's very
touching heartwarming it's very
heartwarming yeah
it's it's even more hot warming hearing
it from you
what is the role of the the ascetic the
renunciant the monk
in the modern age like how do you view
yourself
in that kind of context
it's a role in our tradition
it's not that being a monk makes you
more
enlightened or god-conscious
um one could be in politics one could be
in business one could be an
entertainment one could be an athlete
if if we follow these principles of
being with people
who enlighten us and having a spiritual
practice that we
that we do sincerely and we live with
character and the desire to serve
then one can make just as much
spiritual progress maybe even more
as the bible says be in this world but
not of this world
and and that's really a universal
principle
so being a monk
is a service to society
i'm not a monk because i think that i'm
making more spiritual progress than
other people who are living
with families and who have homes and
jobs
but not having a family of my
own in the sense being celibate
and um
living according to the traditions i do
is an opportunity where i could make the
whole world my family
and i can just my my role is is
to have no other purpose except
to remind people enlightened people
and try to educate and inspire people
um beautiful well part of that is
i mean you have the ashram and you've
got the hospital and
you also have this echo village which i
wanted to hear
a little bit about can you explain what
this is all about
it's called govardhan eco village
and i won't go into the history of it
but the principle of it is
that humanity really needs
to not only intellectually understand
but to see
models of how to apply
the principle that creation is sacred
and all living beings are sacred
um we see so much of the pollution
in the world and so much of the
exploitation of the world
you know there's there's this the the
social
crisis that's happening you know between
races and between prejudice and between
religions
and there's also you know ecological
you know the air the water the the land
being being polluted and
when we understand that all beings
are god's children
all species of life wherever there's
life
there's a desire to be happy there's a
desire to live
and you know i became a vegetarian
50 years ago when i saw
a cow and her little calf
and how much they loved each other and
it was the first time i was so close
and i remember thinking that mother
cares about her little calf as much as
any mother
and that little calf loves the mother
and depends on the mother just like any
child
and why can't we see that they want to
live
and they want to be happy just like us
and um you know
humanity and all beings
are seeking pleasure our speech everyone
is seeking life liberty and the pursuit
of
happiness because everyone's god's child
and everyone should be respected as
god's child and there may
have to be justice for people who
violate other people's rights but it
should be with that spirit
and all of creation
says everything that exists is coming
from the
from the source of all love we call
krishna
or god so all of creation is god's
property how can we
misuse exploit
or pollute sacred property
the very property the very environment
that is we are all completely dependent
on
the idea of mother earth it's a reality
just like an infant baby is completely
dependent on
mother for survival whoever we are in
this world we're completely dependent on
mother earth
for air for food for water for
everything our bodies are composed of
her elements
so um to be compassionate to other
beings
to to be respectful to god
is inseparable from being an
environmentalist
we can't separate them it's hypocrisy to
separate them because they're all
interconnected
and all living beings are interconnected
and to understand this interconnectivity
of creation
is the basic principle of governing
village
so we have models we have environmental
models because we see
in india we're in a village environment
we see so many problems there are
and we have water harvesting because we
understand the value of water there's so
much
drought so many people around us are
committing
suicide due to the poverty based on
drought
but we can teach them how to harvest
water
and have enough water throughout the
year without changing anything except
knowing how to do something and
you know we have people who created a
machine that turns
plastic that pollutes into usable oil
without any without any trace of
pollution in the air
it's all sealed and we make our
bricks out of the ground that we walk on
and they're beautiful bricks that
theoretically the last for hundreds of
years we'll see
but they're beautiful and we do organic
natural farming
we have an animal sanctuary a bird
sanctuary a butterfly sanctuary
and it's all based on spiritual themes
and we take all these various
technologies of
mulching and and and creating
organic natural fertilizers and
pesticides
um and many more things
and we go to the villages hundreds of
villages
and we give them an opportunity to see
how you can improve your life by just
applying these natural principles
yeah yeah yeah what a beautiful
expression
of this ethos of oneness you know the
consistency
with which you practice the philosophy
of bhakti yoga like
very much with boots in the ground i
love that and i feel like
that's a a wonderful model that we need
to bring
you know more to the united states we're
seeing this resurgence of regenerative
farming and
care for the soil and then separate from
that
you know people who are developing
technologies around plastic etc but
to create a model that
is replicable where you're doing all of
these things
in one place to tend to the land in this
practice of of devotion really to
to gaia to mother earth i think is such
a
uh is beautiful we're really trying
over on equal village we have the
governon school of yoga
where we have teachers training and we
have a
a school for ayurveda and a whole
ayurvedic hospital
network which is natural natural
medicine
and we also have a college there
where we're teaching these things and
we've had
universities yale university um
harvard university professors coming for
symposiums and
and and people are coming actually from
all over the world
just to see you know how we're doing
this and
oh that's great right we we recently got
a
award from the united nations
being it was like the first place in the
world
for for um creating
a model of a retreat center that's
environmentally very exemplary
and that's really helping the villages
and the communities around
us oh that's fantastic i want to visit
can i come and visit please we invite
you i would love to do that
um i don't want to take up too much more
of your time but there's two things that
i want to
ask you before i let you go the first
thing is
i know that you you've met a lot of
amazing people
over the course of your lifetime but i
know that you you
had an encounter with barack obama and i
just want to know
what you guys talked about when you met
him
i really found president obama to be a
beautiful man
we didn't speak for a long time but
but quality is oftentimes much more
powerful than quantity of
of time sure i really felt
a deep heart connection and i really
felt
he truly and genuinely um
wanted to do something really good for
america and for the world
and of course in politics there's so
many
challenges and so many um
so many considerations that somebody has
to make but
um we we had a beautiful connection
that's good you're not going to tell me
what you actually talked about
that's a joke you don't have to
well i'll tell you i'll tell you i think
it's better actually okay only if you
feel comfortable maybe it's better if
you don't
like i i feel like you want to keep that
like there's something sacred about that
that you just want to keep to yourself
i'll tell you which is fine
all right go ahead
i he looked at me you know i'm a sadhu
from india i was the only person like
that
but but a fellow chicagoan and when i
told him i'm from chicago
yeah he just he just lit up
you are from chicago
[Laughter]
you know from that point we were just
brothers
all right good i feel better um
last thing and then i'll let you go
which is i want to leave people
with something practical something
tactile that they could practice or
build into their lives that would help
them develop
some spiritual awareness if somebody is
at the starting line of this journey
this adventure and they
think well awakening how do i become
more integrated how do i align my heart
with my head like
these are very ethereal principles right
they're they're elusive it's like well
tell me just
just tell me what i actually should do
like what is a
practice that i can begin
that will perhaps catalyze some
growth or progress in this area one
little
spark if it's fanned and given proper
oxygen
can become a blazing fire
we shouldn't underestimate a spark
so when we come in our life where
there's this spark of an
inclination to understand who
am i and why is there so much suffering
and what is the purpose of life what is
what will make my life truly meaningful
and if there is a god you know
really what is that connection
when that spark of awakening comes
then to seek out people who can
give oxygen to that spark
to have a spiritual practice a
meditation
a chanting of of mantra of god's names
um to actually
fan the spark of our spiritual
inclination
for meaning and purpose and
as we do that then the light grows
brighter and brighter and brighter
and then we can actually give light to
the world
beautifully put thank you for that
and thank you for spending this time
with me
i feel much better than i did an hour
and a half ago how do you feel
you feel good i feel so much better rich
you you are
you are an amazing personality you're
just such a
you're so pleasing to be with and your
questions are so insightful and so
so well thought out and and from the
heart
my ego thanks you
actually there's two egos there's
there's the really go and there's the
false ego
and the really goal is
that i'm an eternal soul an instrument
of love
part of god and the false ego is
um what separates us from everybody
else the really go unites us so
i your your real ego is something very
very
beautiful and we all have to you know as
the real ego
becomes more and more stronger and
emerges then the false eagle
um dissipates
yeah well may we embrace the real ego
i'm working on the other part
it's a work in progress it's like in
northern california sometimes there's
such a heavy
fog but when the sun starts rising then
the fog has dissipated dissipates
yes lovely well promise me
that if you find yourself in california
that we can do this in person once again
i would love to do that
and and i i want to thank you so very
much for
including me and i want to thank all of
your
viewers or listeners for so kindly and
patiently
being with us today if people
want to learn more about you they should
pick up your books the journey home the
journey within
both fantastic reads uh where's the best
place to
direct people online who want to learn
more
um amazon.com has both of them
but your website radnoswami.com
that's there's a on facebook
also on the website it's there
good well i'll link up all of those
destinations in the show notes
and until we meet in person my friend
thank you
for spending this time with me i really
greatly appreciate
it and i wish you well and continued
health and happiness as you
spread your light across the globe
because we need you
we need you now more than ever well if i
have brought some happiness to your
precious heart rich
then my day is very auspicious and
wonderful
okay good all right thank you and
with that we conclude thank you
peace blatz
[Music]
you